talking about businesses listen if
you're a business owner across
america you know the story better than
anyone went through the ringer right
indeed they have and here's a few others
who've done it as well listen here
this is just a slow bleed um we have 100
of the bills with 33 percent
occupancy no one's coming back to the
gym
governor cuomo has done his job and his
job is to keep people fearful
of the one thing that can help them and
that's actually getting fit and staying
healthy that man there
was gym owner charles casara from
october of 2020
trying to keep his business alive amid
new york governor andrew cuomo's
crushing lockdown
now you fast forward a few months later
and now the state gyms are finally back
to full capacity
but are things looking better charles
cassara the owner of sc fitness out on
long island is with us here today in
manhattan
good morning to you good morning obvious
question
are you back we're back in the technical
sense that we're
allowed to be 100 capacity
uh masks are coming off but as far as
getting people to come back
that's a different story and what do you
hear from them are they fearful to come
back or do they just get out of the
habit
well you know they released the new cdc
guidelines and governor cuomo did
you know adapt them into small
businesses but there's a lot of
different caveats with them
for instance in order for us to get rid
of the social distancing inside of our
gyms
we have to take people's vaccination
cards
this is creating a big problem between
people who
don't want to give it or have been
vaccinated so a lot of gym owners
actually yesterday lost i would say
you know another five to ten percent of
their overall business
and if you don't take it then we can
have the masks off but we have to keep
social distance
and if we're going to keep social
distance then 100 capacity
is predicated on the six feet so that
doesn't work so how do we
uh gain any profits one of the things
that
i was surprised by but it's important
for people to know this is that gyms
were not
eligible for ppp loans so a lot of gyms
are generally if you want to take in the
city here um boutique
orientated so they don't have a lot of
employees
so they didn't apply or get any ppp
money
and that was a big problem in our
industry plus we also know that in the
beginning stages it was riddled with
fraud
so instead of fixing it what did we do
we just put more money back into
a program that didn't work and we also
know that the banks
gave privilege to their larger companies
that were with them
so we tend to either 1099 a lot of
employees
or we take profit share checks both of
which we can't apply for the ppp
so since being closed in march to being
open in september
landlords wanted money no doubt that sue
so
we got nothing we just saw you from
seven months ago
now seven months later and i was hoping
for a little more optimism but i
understand where you're coming from
you sue the governor of new york we did
try and reopen what happened
so um we basically banded together we
got a lot of gyms together since we
weren't considered an essential
business even though we think we are and
we got together and we sued
because we feel that the governor's
rules were
arbitrary and over the course of time it
proved that we were right
and right before we were supposed to go
to court and the governor was supposed
to show
cause and discovery they opened us
no one knew we were being open not mayor
bill de blasio not the department of
health
not the sheriff's departments no one
knew because over the weekend
they knew they were gonna have to come
to court they couldn't show cause
they didn't have any proof for shutting
us down they had none of the science to
prove it
and they opened us up okay so we're here
on this beautiful day the weather is
going to continue to get better and
warmer
people are outside and they go to the
beach this weekend they might think i
need to get back to the gym like what's
your pitch
to try to get people to come back so at
the end of the day our pitch has always
been
that we were the one industry that
honestly should have stayed open because
your immune system is really what's
important
about you know protecting yourself from
covet yes the vaccine and if you want to
get it that's great and that's the way
you know to go but your immune system
who can do that
that's the gems so if everybody's been
locked down and
wanted such a great point back into
fearless
um you know find a gym that
is willing to accommodate you depending
on on where your stance is
and and let's start to get back when we
introduced you talked about staying
healthy back in october i did i think so
i mean so many people we
we can relate to this yeah about trying
to keep your
keep yourself in line you know we fight
against obesity which nobody wants to
talk about
we fight against hypertension and
diabetes and all the things
that were main contributors towards
people passing more during coverage so
well good luck to you
i would like to stay in touch and see
how it goes and hopefully everybody get
back to gym and take care of themselves
that's a good investment to make i agree
all right charles thank you thank you